Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. When I agreed to do this podcast with Tom Holland, the one thing I dreaded was that on a Saturday morning I'd be dragged out of bed to do a podcast about some obscure medieval saint. And lo and behold, that's precisely what we're doing in this special Rest Is History podcast about the life of St Cuthbert. Now, Tom, please explain to me.
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《The Rest Is History》。当我同意和汤姆·霍兰德一起做这个播客时，我最害怕的一件事就是周六一大早被从被窝里拽起来，做一个关于某个晦涩难懂的中世纪圣人的播客。你看，这不，这正是我们在这一期关于圣卡斯伯特生平的特别版《The Rest Is History》播客中所要做的事。那么，汤姆，请给我解释一下。
He's not an obscure saint. He's the patron saint of Northumbria. And I think that most people, myself included, think that he should properly be the patron saint of England. So it's big news that today is his saint's day. So this is St Cuthbert's day. So this is St. Cuthbert's day. Yeah. This is St. Cuthbert's day. He died 1,334 years ago. So that's AD 687 on the 20th of March. A landmark anniversary. Landmark anniversary. And I think it's a big day. It's one of my favourite days of the year. And it started off as a joke that Jonathan Wilson, who we had on our most recent podcast talking about football.
他并不是一个无名之辈。他是诺森比亚的主保圣人。而且我认为大多数人，包括我自己，都认为他理应成为英格兰的主保圣人。所以今天是他的瞻礼日，这可是件大事。所以今天是圣卡斯伯特日。所以今天是圣卡斯伯特日。没错。今天是圣卡斯伯特日。他在1334年前去世。也就是公元687年3月20日。一个具有里程碑意义的周年纪念日。具有里程碑意义的周年纪念日。我认为这是一个大日子。这是我一年中最喜欢的日子之一。这一切最初只是个玩笑，当时乔纳森·威尔逊，也就是我们上一期谈论足球的嘉宾……
He is a great football man. Those who've listened to it will perhaps recognise from his accent that he's a man of the North East. And Cuthbert was likewise a man of the North East. And so we got into the habit of meeting with Jonathan and a few friends to celebrate St. Cuthbert, to toast his memory. And it's become a kind of annual occurrence.
他是个狂热的足球迷。听过那一期节目的朋友或许能从他的口音中听出他是东北部人。而卡斯伯特同样也是东北部人。因此，我们养成了与乔纳森和几个朋友聚会庆祝圣卡斯伯特、向他的记忆敬酒的习惯。这已经成为一种年度传统。
And actually one of the reasons that I wanted to do it this year was that last year our celebration of St. Cuthbert's Day was the first thing that got kiboshed by the lockdown, by the COVID lockdown. Yes. And it kind of, it actually really, it really kind of, that was the first time that I felt, oh God, this is going to be weird. Both because I missed it, but also because Cuthbert was a saint who lived in a time of terrible plague. The accounts of his life, endlessly, it's kind of taken for granted. He'll turn up and a plague is raging.
事实上，我今年想要做这个节目的原因之一是，去年我们对圣卡斯伯特日的庆祝活动，是第一件被封锁政策、新冠封锁政策搅黄的事情。是的。而且它那种，它真的，它真的让人觉得，那是第一次让我感到，天哪，这太诡异了。一方面是因为我很想念它，另一方面是因为卡斯伯特是一位生活在可怕瘟疫时期的圣人。关于他生平的记载中，无一例外地，这被视为理所当然。他会现身，而当时瘟疫正肆虐。
People will die of it and he brought incredible healing powers kind of supernatural healing powers but he also brought kind of comfort and concern so all right um let's get let's get to the nitty-gritty um what century are we in and what's the story basically we're in the seventh century and we're in um a north so this is before the kingdom of england this is when um what will become england is divided up among rival anglo-saxon kingdoms um we are in the kingdom of northumbria yeah um and uh it's a time when um christianity has come both from Ireland and from Rome. So it's pre-Viking. It's pre-Viking.
人们死于瘟疫，而他带来了不可思议的治愈力量——某种超自然的治愈力量，但他同时也带来了安慰和关怀。所以，好吧，嗯，让我们切入正题吧。我们生活在哪个世纪？故事的大致背景是什么？基本上，我们身处公元7世纪，而且是在一个北方……所以这是在英格兰王国建立之前，当时日后将成为英格兰的土地被互相敌对的盎格鲁-撒克逊王国所瓜分。我们身处诺森比亚王国。是的。而且，这是一个基督教同时从爱尔兰和罗马传来的时期。所以这是维京时期之前。这是维京时期之前。
It's pre-Viking. So it's a period when the old gods are kind of retreating. And in fact, in Bede's account of Cuthbert, there's this kind of amazing detail where some monks are sailing out across the mouth of the Tyne and the wind blows up and starts blowing them out to sea. And a bunch of lads on the shore all start laughing. As they would. Yeah, it's kind of Dark Ages viz, I guess.
这是维京时期之前。所以这是一个旧神正在退场的时期。事实上，在比德对卡斯伯特的记载中，有一个非常惊人的细节：一些僧侣乘船驶过泰恩河口时，突然刮起大风，把他们吹向大海深处。岸上的一群小伙子都哈哈大笑起来。理所当然会这样。是的，这大概可以说是“黑暗时代的滑稽画”吧。
Yeah. And Cuthbert says to them, you know, why are you doing this? These poor guys are going to be swept to their deaths. And they say, well, we don't care because these monks are banishing our gods and we don't know what we're meant to do anymore. And Cuthbert kneels down and he prays and miraculously the wind changes and the monks are swept back in. But there's a glimpse there of what Cuthbert actually represents, which is a kind of a revolution, a process of revolution, the introduction of Christianity, both from Ireland and from Rome. So it's kind of mixed, but it's felt as radical. But what you see in the life of Cuthbert is why Christianity works, why it beds down. So who is he? Where's he born? Well, ironically for a man who comes to be associated with the emergent kingdom of England, he's actually born in what is now Scotland. He's a Scot. He's not.
是的。卡斯伯特对他们说，你知道，你们为什么要这么做？这些可怜的人会被卷入海中送命的。而他们说，哦，我们才不在乎呢，因为这些僧侣赶走了我们的神，我们现在都不知道该怎么办了。卡斯伯特跪下来祈祷，奇迹般地，风向变了，僧侣们被吹了回来。但从这其中，我们可以一窥卡斯伯特真正代表的东西——那是一种革命，一个革命的过程，基督教的引入（同时来自爱尔兰和罗马）。所以这有点混杂，但人们觉得它是激进的。不过，从卡斯伯特的生平中，你能看出为什么基督教能发挥作用，为什么它能扎根。那么他是谁？他在哪里出生的？有趣的是，对于一个日后与新兴的英格兰王国联系在一起的人来说，他实际上出生在如今的苏格兰境内。他是个苏格兰人。他才不是。
He's a Northumbrian because, of course, the kingdom of Northumbria reached all the way up to the Firth of Forth. Okay. So he's perhaps born in the vicinity of Melrose, perhaps Dunbar, somewhere around like somewhere that. He seems to have been of aristocratic background. He's described as a young boy who enjoyed his sport so of course sportsmen like you will will empathize with that well i guess kind of thinking you know the the grand sporting tradition of the northeast because we've had both we've had dan jackson talking about that jackie milburn previous yeah all that bobby charlton and uh cuff butbert is described as playing a ball game.
他是诺森比亚人，因为当然，诺森比亚王国的领土一直延伸到福斯湾。好吧。所以他大概出生在梅尔罗斯附近，也许是邓巴，或者诸如此类的地方。他似乎有着贵族背景。据描述，他小时候很喜欢运动，所以像你这样的运动员当然会对这一点感同身受。嗯，我大概能体会到，你知道的，东北部宏伟的体育传统，因为我们有丹·杰克逊谈过这个，还有杰基·米尔本，以前的那些……是的，还有博比·查尔顿，而且据说卡斯伯特以前经常玩球类游戏。
So maybe, probably football, maybe cricket. Who knows? Can't say. But he was clearly a kind of Gazza-esque young man. That's not a comparison I was expecting. But then he has a kind of a conversion. Right. And then but then he has a kind of a conversion and and what he sees a vision of angels descending and a great beam of light and then a figure rising up to the sky. And this figure he subsequently learns is St.
所以也许，可能是足球，也可能是板球。谁知道呢？说不准。但他显然是个有点像加扎的年轻男子。这个比喻我倒是没想到。不过后来他经历了一种转变。对。然后，接着他经历了一种转变，他看到了天使降临的异象，一束巨大的光芒，然后是一个人形升上天空。他后来得知这个人物就是圣
Aidan, an Irish monk who has founded a monastery on an island called Lindisfarne. That'll be very well known. And and kuthbert decides that he is going to devote his life to christ and he turns up at um priory of of melrose and we're told again by bead that he arrives with a spear and on a horse so that suggests that actually he's a he's quite well born so or that he's why has he got a spear is he a soldier or do people just this is a, because this is a violent age. This is a violent age.
艾丹，一个在林迪斯法恩岛建立修道院的爱尔兰僧侣。这个岛非常有名。卡斯伯特决定将自己的一生奉献给基督，于是他来到了梅尔罗斯修道院。比德再次告诉我们，他到达时带着长矛，骑着马，这表明他实际上出身相当显贵。或者说，他为什么拿着长矛？他是个士兵，还是说人们只是……因为这是一个充满暴力的时代。这是一个充满暴力的时代。
It's an age of plague and it's an age of war. And Cuthbert, by abandoning his horse, by abandoning his spear, is essentially becoming a slave of Christ. And he casts off all the privileges of his class. He lives an incredibly ascetic life. This is a man who in the middle of the night goes down into the North Sea, stands up to his neck, praying, comes back up as the chill wind is whipping off the North Sea in the early dawn.
这是一个充满瘟疫的时代，也是一个充满战争的时代。而卡斯伯特通过抛弃他的马，抛弃他的长矛，本质上是成为了基督的奴隶。他抛弃了他阶级的所有特权。他过着极其苦行的生活。这是一个在半夜三更走入北海、把水没过脖子进行祈祷，然后在清晨北海刺骨寒风呼啸时走上来的人。
Isn't that what people in the North do on like New Year's Day and stuff? They go for dips to show their hardiness. But they go for dips, but they don't stand for hours at an end up to their neck. But there's this wonderful detail, however, that as Cuthbert is standing on the shore, sea otters come and they warm his feet and then they slip back into the sea. And this is kind of one of the wonderful details about Cuthbert. That's just a bit weird, Tom.
北方人不是在元旦之类的时候也这么做吗？他们去冬泳来展示自己的强壮。但他们是去冬泳，而不是一连几个小时把水没过脖子站在那里。不过，这里有一个非常奇妙的细节：当卡斯伯特站在岸边时，海獭游过来温暖他的脚，然后又滑回海里。这是关于卡斯伯特的奇妙细节之一。这听起来有点诡异，汤姆。
That's a bit weird, Tom. That's a bit weird. Well, but there's a lot more. Cuthbert is a man who sees angels. He can heal the sick. He can banish fire. He can make the wind turn. And he communes with the natural world. So sea otters come and warm his feet. Eagles bring him fish when he's hungry. He can understand things from the pattern of the flying of the birds. And the truth is that if you want a model for, say, Gandalf or Merlin,
这有点诡异，汤姆。这真有点诡异。好吧，不过还有更多。卡斯伯特是一个能看到天使的人。他能治愈病人。他能驱散烈火。他能让风向转变。他与自然界交流。所以海獭会来温暖他的脚。当他饿了的时候，老鹰会给他带鱼来。他能从鸟类的飞行轨迹中理解事物。事实是，如果你想要找一个类似甘道夫或梅林的模板——
a man who has an incredible power that is actually greater than that that he would have had if he'd remained a warrior. Okay. But let me interrupt you, Tom. So where are you getting all this stuff from? I mean, how do we – is this sort of saints' lives written down by monks or is it a chronicle or what exactly is it? And was it written at the time or is this some fable told long afterwards so this is another reason why i thought it would be great to do it on this podcast because in a sense this is where the tradition that that this podcast and other history podcasts and people who
一个拥有不可思议力量的人，而这种力量实际上比他如果继续当个战士所能拥有的力量还要巨大。好吧。不过打断你一下，汤姆。那你这些材料都是从哪儿弄来的？我的意思是，我们怎么——这到底是僧侣写下来的圣徒传记，还是一部编年史，到底是什么？而且这是当时写的，还是后来很久才流传的寓言？这也是为什么我认为在这次播客中讨论这个很好的原因，因为在某种程度上，这就是这个播客、其他历史播客以及那些
write about history and yeah i like the fact this podcast has a tradition now it does because because essentially it it begins with this because the one of the guys who writes about it is Bede. And Bede writes the first great history of what you might call the English people. And Bede writes this life of Cuthbert. And he specifies in his opening to it that he has researched it, that he's spoken to people who knew Cuthbert, and that these are living traditions that he's writing down. And there's another life as well, which is earlier, which is also clearly written by someone who knew Cuthbert quite well. And I think what's haunting about it is the sense of kind of anecdotes and stories that have,
撰写历史的人所承袭的传统……是的，我喜欢这个播客现在也有了自己的传统。确实如此，因为本质上它就是从这里开始的，因为其中一个撰写这段历史的人就是比德。比德撰写了第一部伟大的、你可以称之为英国人民的历史。比德撰写了这本《卡斯伯特传》。他在开篇时明确指出，他进行过研究，与认识卡斯伯特的人交谈过，他所写下的都是活生生的传统。还有另一部更早的传记，显然也是由一个相当了解卡斯伯特的人写的。我认为最令人难忘的是那种轶事和故事的感觉，它们
they're clearly true. There's clearly some kind, there are memories that are told of Cuthbert that have been kind of retold and retold. So there's a story. So Cuthbert is closely associated with royal women who have become abbesses. So this is a period in which women have incredible sacral power as well and they're generally princesses are of the royal northumbrian
显然是真实的。关于卡斯伯特的记忆显然是经过了一代又一代的复述。所以这里有个故事。卡斯伯特与成为女修道院院长的王室女性有着紧密的联系。所以这是一个女性也拥有不可思议的神圣力量的时期，她们通常是诺森比亚王室的公主。
household and there's one who has the brilliant name alf lad um and she is the abbess of whitby and she she comes to meet with cuthbert and anduthbert sits down at table with her, although he barely eats anything. He's incredibly ascetic. And as they're sitting at table, we're told he suddenly has a kind of he goes and has a strange fit. He sits there and everyone's kind of staring at him, snapping their fingers in front of his eyes. Nothing happens. And then he wakens up from his trance and says, what's going on? And he says, someone I was watching someone in your Abbey going up to heaven. I saw angels come and collect
有一个女人的名字非常棒，叫艾尔弗莱德（Aelflaed），她是惠特比的女修道院院长。她来见卡斯伯特，卡斯伯特和她同桌吃饭，尽管他几乎不吃什么东西。他过着极其苦行的生活。正当他们坐着吃饭时，我们被告知他突然有了一种……他经历了一次奇怪的发作。他坐在那里，所有人都盯着他看，在他眼前打响指。什么都没有发生。然后他从出神中醒过来，问：“发生什么事了？”他说：“我刚刚看到你们修道院里的某个人正在升入天堂。我看到天使来收集他的灵魂，并把它带到天堂。”艾尔弗莱德说：“好吧，你知道是谁吗？”卡斯伯特说：“明天当我主持弥撒时，你会告诉我。”于是艾尔弗莱德派出一个信使，得知死者是一个牧羊人。当卡斯伯特主持弥撒时，他来到了悼念逝者的环节。艾尔弗莱德冲进来，说：“就是那个牧羊人。”于是卡斯伯特为他举行了悼念。所以令人瞩目的是，卡斯伯特与一位出身极其高贵的诺森比亚王室成员之间有着如此亲密的关系。但同样引人注目的是，他们在谈论一个牧羊人。我们怎么强调都不为过，那就是
his soul and take it up to heaven. And Alphad says, well, you know, who? And Cuthbert says, you will tell me tomorrow when I am celebrating mass. And so Alphad sends off a messenger, gets told that it's a shepherd who's died. And as Cuthbert is celebrating mass, he comes to the point where you remember those who've died. Al-Flaad bursts in, says, it's this shepherd, and Cuthbert commemorates him. So what's striking about that is both the intimacy that Cuthbert has with a very, very high-born Northumbrian royal. But also the fact that they are talking about a shepherd. And it's hard to overemphasise the degree to which
高社会地位的人通常是不会关心牧羊人的生死的。所以你可以清楚地看到这一点，既能看到卡斯伯特的权力，也能看到为什么基督教能如此迅速地扎根。它对精英阶层、对王室成员有吸引力。是的。但它对穷人同样有吸引力。我们一次又一次地被告知，尽管卡斯伯特赢得了权高位重之人的尊敬，但他心里始终装着穷人，装着那些正在受苦的人。他总是急切地确保自己能够治愈他们，给他们食物，给他们庇护，无论需要什么。所以我觉得他是一个备受爱戴的人。不过，这在多大程度上——基本上，我的意思是，圣徒传记当时不是已经有既定的范式了吗？
people of high status generally are not bothered with the death of shepherds. And so you can see exactly that, both the power of Cuthbert, but also why Christianity puts down roots so quickly. It has something for the elites, for those who are royal. Yeah. But it also has something for those who are poor. And we're told again and again that although Cuthbert commands the respect of those who are very powerful, he also always has in his mind those who are poor, those who are suffering. And he is always concerned to make sure that he can heal them, give them food, give them shelter, whatever. So he's a very loved man, I think. How much is this, though, just basically, I mean, there were established formulas for saints' lives, weren't there?
高地位的人通常不会为牧羊人的死而烦扰。所以你可以清楚地看到这一点，既有卡斯伯特的权势，也解释了为什么基督教能够如此迅速地扎根。它既能吸引精英和王室成员，是的。但它也能吸引穷人。我们一次又一次地被告知，尽管卡斯伯特赢得了权高位重之人的尊敬，但他的心中始终装着穷人和受苦受难的人。他总是关切于确保自己能治愈他们，给他们提供食物、住所，等等。所以我觉得他是一个备受喜爱的人。不过，这在多大程度上其实只是一些既定的圣徒传记模式呢？
So how much is this just sort of recapping the traditional formulae for saints' lives? You know, history in its early years, in its early centuries, followed set rules set rules you know people behaved in certain ways emperors saints bishops kings yeah how is cuthbert different is cuthbert different or is this just basically following the traditional tram lines well um cuthbert is is bred of an age where holy men are vested with an incredible sense of power so this is also for instance on the other end of the former roman empire this is the age of instance, on the other end of the former Roman empire, this is the age of Muhammad, very kind of different tradition,
所以这在多大程度上只是在套用圣徒传记的传统范式？你知道，早期的历史，在它的早期世纪里，遵循着既定的规则，既定规则。你知道，人们会以特定的方式行事，皇帝、圣徒、主教、国王，是的。卡斯伯特有什么不同？卡斯伯特与众不同吗，还是这基本上只是遵循传统的陈规旧俗？嗯……卡斯伯特诞生于一个圣人被赋予不可思议的权力感的时代，所以这也是，例如，在罗马帝国另一端的那个时期——也就是穆罕默德的时代，虽然是一个非常不同的传统，
but you can see bread of the kind of same matrix perhaps. And so you're right that there are absolutely kind of traditions specifically within the Christian one that Cuthbert embodies. But I think that what makes Cuthbert's reputation different is firstly what I was saying, that these lives are clearly written out of a sense of awe and love for him. And they bear the definite imprint of personal experiences
但你可以看出它们或许孕育自相同的母体。所以你是对的，基督宗教内部确实存在卡斯伯特所体现的特定传统。但我认为，让卡斯伯特的声誉与众不同的首先正如我所说的那样，这些传记显然是在对他充满敬畏和热爱的基础上写出来的。它们带有鲜明的个人经历的印记，
to a degree that I think is unusual in saints' lives. And the other thing is that these lives are written because Cuthbert comes to have after after his life, in death, an incredible potency. Well, let's do that after the break, maybe. We've done Cuthbert Alive. We'll do After the Break. We'll do his death and his afterlife, which is an amazing story. I think in many ways even more interesting than his life. Well, that is something for our remaining listeners to look forward to.
其程度在我看来在圣徒传记中是不多见的。另一个原因是，这些传记之所以被写下来，是因为卡斯伯特在死后依然拥有不可思议的巨大影响力。好吧，我们也许可以在中场休息后再谈这个。我们已经讲了活着的卡斯伯特。我们接下来要讲中场休息后的内容。我们要讲他的死以及他的死后哀荣，这是一个惊人的故事。我认为在许多方面，这甚至比他生前还要有趣。好吧，这确实是给我们剩下的听众值得期待的内容。
We'll see you again after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
我们中场休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are discussing the life of St Cuthbert. It is St Cuthbert's Day.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家附赠节目以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。我们正在讨论圣卡斯伯特的生平。今天是圣卡斯伯特日。
Tom Holland is brimming with enthusiasm. We've been talking about St Cuthbert. It is St. Cuthbert's day. Tom Holland is brimming with enthusiasm. We've been talking about St. Cuthbert alive. Tom, so St. Cuthbert dies, and this is a big, this is really where the story gets juicy, right, with St. Cuthbert's death. Yes. So a dead saint is a very valuable commodity. So the moment Cuthbert dies, beacons are lit.
汤姆·霍兰德热情高涨。我们一直在讨论圣卡斯伯特。今天是圣卡斯伯特日。汤姆·霍兰德热情高涨。我们一直在谈论活着的圣卡斯伯特。汤姆，那么圣卡斯伯特死了，而这正是故事变得有趣的地方，对吧，随着圣卡斯伯特的死。是的。所以一个死去的圣人是非常宝贵的资源。因此，就在卡斯伯特死的那一刻，信号灯被点燃了。
He's on a kind of a far island out in the wilds of the North Sea. And his body is brought over to Lindisfarne, wrapped up, buried. And 11 years later, the monks look at the body and it's fully preserved. Miraculous. That is miraculous. And the reason they do that is that everything associated with Cuthbert has been doing amazing miracles. So his shoes cures people, his comb cures people. A boldness, presumably.
他当时在一个位于北海荒野的偏远岛屿上。他的遗体被运送到林迪斯法恩，包裹好，埋葬。11年后，僧侣们查看遗体，发现它完好无损。奇迹。这真是个奇迹。他们这样做的原因是，与卡斯伯特有关的一切都展现过惊人的奇迹。所以他的鞋子能治病，他的梳子能治病。大概能治秃顶吧。
I'm sure, yeah. The body is particularly potent. And over the course of the century that follows, it becomes a great object of pilgrimage because not just across England, but across the whole of Northern Christian, Northern Europe, people are coming to Lindisfarne to pray at St. Cuthbert's because it's, you know, it's the kind of equivalent of a Pfizer vaccine.
我确信，是的。这具遗体尤其具有强大的力量。在随后的一个世纪里，它成为了一个伟大的朝圣对象，因为不仅在英格兰各地，而且在整个基督教化的北欧，人们纷纷来到林迪斯法恩，在圣卡斯伯特墓前祈祷，因为这，你知道的，这就相当于辉瑞疫苗。
It's, it's that, that important. And that's a hell of a journey, Tom. I mean, if you're coming from or something, I mean,
它的重要性，就是有这么重要。那可是一段漫长的旅程，汤姆。我的意思是，如果你从什么地方来，我的意思是，
that's, you know, this is like a massive expedition. And do you have any sense of numbers? I mean, are we talking, are we talking dozens? Well, we, the, the's, you know, this is like a massive expedition. And do you have any sense of numbers? I mean, are we talking dozens? Well, the measurement of how many people are coming is that Lindisfarne becomes spectacularly rich because every time they come, they bring an offering. And so you have this island off the North Sea, exposed, distant, absolutely stuffed full of gold and treasure. And of course, in 793, this attracts the attention of various gentlemen from across the North Sea,
你知道，这就像是一次庞大的远征。你知道大概的人数吗？我的意思是，我们是在说几十人吗？好吧，衡量有多少人前来的标准是，林迪斯法恩变得极其富有，因为他们每次来都会带来供奉。所以你拥有了北海中这样一座孤岛，暴露在外，偏远，却绝对塞满了黄金和宝藏。当然，在公元793年，这引起了来自北海彼岸的各路绅士的注意——
the Vikings. And the Viking Age begins with the sack of Lindisfarne. And they keep coming back and coming back and coming back. And they're coming back for Cuthbert's loot, basically, for the loot that's loot, basically. For the loot that's been accumulated from the tourist trade. And it all gets too much. And 875, that's almost a century after the monks, you know, fed up with this. And so they upload Cuthbert in his coffin and they transport it. And essentially what they seem to be doing with that is that they take it around all the various lands that the monastery of Lindisfarne has come to be given over the course of the century.
维京人。而维京时代就以洗劫林迪斯法恩拉开序幕。他们一次又一次、没完没了地回来。他们回来基本上是为了抢夺卡斯伯特的战利品，为了从旅游业中积累的战利品。这一切最终变得无法收拾。公元875年，也就是僧侣们不堪忍受的近一个世纪后，他们厌倦了这一切。于是他们把卡斯伯特的遗体连同棺材一起装船运走。本质上，他们这样做似乎是将遗体带过这一个世纪以来林迪斯法恩修道院获赠的所有不同土地。
And they're taking the body as a kind of stamp. So they're saying, you know, here it is. And this body continues to do incredible miracles. And what's interesting is that it seems to impress the Vikings as much as the native Northumbrians. And so in 883, there's a king, he's actually formerly a slave, a Viking slave who becomes a king called Guthrid. Oh, yeah. I've read about him in Bernard Cornwell. That's right. So Bernard Cornwell writes about it in a sceptical way. But it's evident that to everyone, Cuthbert's body is just the most remarkable, supernatural, terrifying thing that there is. And the body gets taken to York when Guthrid is crowned. And Guthrid gives all the land between the Tine and the Tees to the body, to St. Cuthbert. To the body. So basically, for most of the 9th century and into the 10th century, the guy who is ruling the lands between the Tine and the Tees is a dead body.
他们带着这具遗体作为某种权力的印章。所以他们是在说，看，它在这里。而这具遗体继续创造着不可思议的奇迹。有趣的是，它似乎对维京人的震撼不亚于本土的诺森比亚人。所以在公元883年，有一位国王，他以前其实是个奴隶，一个成为国王的维京奴隶，名叫古特里德（Guthrid）。哦，对。我在伯纳德·康沃尔的书里读到过他。没错。所以伯纳德·康沃尔在书中对此持怀疑态度。但很明显，对所有人来说，卡斯伯特的遗体简直是最非凡、最超自然、最令人敬畏的存在。当古特里德加冕时，这具遗体被带到了约克。而古特里德将泰恩河和蒂斯河之间的所有土地都赐予了这具遗体，赐予了圣卡斯伯特。赐予了一具尸体。所以基本上，在整个9世纪的大部分时间以及10世纪，统治泰恩河和蒂斯河之间土地的统治者是一具尸体。
It's the late St. Cuthbert. Brilliant. And any Viking who gives St. Cuthbert shit comes to a horrible end. So there is one Viking who tries to break into the shrine that's been set up at Chesterless Street, the old Roman fort. And the floor opens and the Viking gets swallowed up and goes to hell. And so after that, you know, people are not going to give Cuthbert any grief. And so what that means is that a dead body is perhaps the most significant lord in early 10th century England. I can think of two really good parallels for that from either ends of the historical spectrum. So one, which some listeners may already have thought of, is the body of Alexander the Great.
已故的圣卡斯伯特。太绝了。任何给圣卡斯伯特找麻烦的维京人都落得个可怕的下场。曾有个维京人试图闯入切斯特勒斯特里特（一座古罗马堡垒）建立的神社，结果地板裂开，那个维京人被吞没并坠入地狱。所以在那之后，你知道的，人们再也不敢给卡斯伯特找任何麻烦了。这意味着，一具尸体或许是10世纪初英格兰最重要的领袖。我能想到两个非常好的历史对照，分别来自历史光谱的两端。其中一个，一些听众可能已经想到了，就是亚历山大大帝的遗体。
So Alexander the Great dies after all his conquests. And then there's a big tussle, isn't there, for his body. It's basically stolen by his mate Ptolemy, who takes it to Egypt. And the body of Alexander, which is sort of, you know, it's buried with all sort of honours and stuff in Egypt, in Alexandria, is the sort of badge of legitimacy, isn't it? And bodies were a kind of badge of power and legitimacy.
亚历山大大帝征战结束后去世了。然后，你知道的，为了争夺他的遗体发生了一场大战。他的遗体基本上被他的好友托勒密偷走并带到了埃及。亚历山大的遗体——它在埃及亚历山大港受到各种荣誉安葬——是一种合法性的象征，不是吗？尸体曾是一种权力和合法性的象征。
Except I don't think that Alexander's body does miracles. No, that's right. And really, the thing with Cuthbert is that it… But he was a god. Yes, yes. Cuthbert wasn't even a god. Cuthbert was just a saint. Alexander was a god.
不过我不认为亚历山大的遗体能创造奇迹。不，确实如此。真的，卡斯伯特的奇迹在于它……但他是个神。是的，是的。卡斯伯特甚至都不是神。卡斯伯特只是个圣人。亚历山大是个神。
But Cuthbert is capable of miracles, and therefore that's the basis of his power. Okay. Although, interestingly, with Alexander, I mean, there's this kind of wonderful theory that his body vanishes at around the same time that a Venetian flotilla arrives in Alexandria and steals the body of St. Mark. So I always loved the idea that actually the body of St. Mark in Venice is the body of Alexander, which would be wonderful. So here's my other example. Now, the thing about St. Cuthbert you were saying was that his body was miraculously preserved intact after his death. And, of course, there is a body in the world, which some listeners will have seen, which is miraculously preserved, of another revolutionary who is the sort of badge of legitimacy of a state and that's lenin have you been to lenin's have you seen lenin and i have yes i have yes i've
但卡斯伯特有能力创造奇迹，因此这是他力量的基础。好吧。不过有趣的是，关于亚历山大，有一个美妙的理论，那就是他的遗体在大约同一时间消失了，当时一支威尼斯舰队抵达亚历山大港并偷走了圣马可的遗体。所以我一直很喜欢这个想法：威尼斯的圣马可遗体其实就是亚历山大的遗体，那可真是太棒了。这是我的另一个例子。现在，关于圣卡斯伯特，你刚才说他的遗体在死后奇迹般地完好保存了下来。当然，世界上确实有一具遗体，一些听众可能已经见过了，它同样被奇迹般地保存了下来，那是另一位革命者的遗体，他是一个国家的合法性象征，那就是列宁。你去过列宁的……你见过列宁吗？我去过，是的。我去看过。
threaded past it's very strange isn't it to kind of queue up and go into that mausoleum which is designed like a pyramid you know it's got this sort of pyramidal design he looks like robin cook but it's just a wax work isn't he that's the extraordinary thing they pumped it with so much i don't know formaldehyde or whatever it is it's just this sort of weird plastic looking and they have had arguments in the russian parliament about whether they should just replace him with a resin you know a resin copy because basically the lenin in but that's the that's sort of the same thing isn't it it? The body has become an emblem of authenticity, a really weird sort of parallel.
排队走过它，非常诡异，不是吗？排队进入那个设计得像金字塔一样的陵墓，你知道的，它有一种金字塔似的设计。他看起来有点像罗宾·库克，但那只是一尊蜡像，不是吗？这才是最不可思议的地方。他们在里面注入了太多的——我不知道是甲醛还是别的什么东西，它看起来就是那种诡异的塑料质感。俄罗斯议会甚至曾争论过是否应该用树脂（你知道的，树脂复制品）来替换他，因为基本上列宁的……但这其实是一回事，不是吗？遗体已经成为了一种真实性的象征，一个非常诡异的平行对照。
Yes, to a degree. So the way in which possession of his body serves to legitimise a broader authority. So that's why Guthrie, the Viking king, is patron of Cuthbert, because it legitimizes him. But the king who really exploits this is Athelstan, the grandson of Alfred the Great, and in a sense, the first English king, who he is riding up from Winchester
是的，在某种程度上。拥有他的遗体可以用来使更广泛的统治权合法化。这就是为什么维京国王古特里德要成为卡斯伯特的赞助人，因为这使他合法化。但真正充分利用这一点的国王是埃塞尔斯坦，他是阿尔弗雷德大帝的孙子，从某种意义上说，也是第一位英格兰国王。他从温彻斯特骑马赶来
to smite the Scots who are in rebellion. And he pauses off in Chester-le-Street and he pays a visit to Cuthbert. And the grave is, the coffin is opened and Athelstan leaves various gifts within the coffin. And Athelstan is very respectful of Cuthbert because Cuthbert had appeared to his grandfather Alfred on the Isle of Athelni. So everyone knows the story of the Alfred burning the cakes. But there's another food-related story about Alfred on Athelni that he's sitting there alone, feeling hungry, pondering how to defeat the Vikings.
去痛击叛乱的苏格兰人。他在切斯特勒斯特里特驻足，拜访了卡斯伯特。棺材被打开了，埃塞尔斯坦在棺材里留下了各种各样的礼物。埃塞尔斯坦对卡斯伯特非常敬重，因为卡斯伯特曾在阿瑟尼岛上显灵给他的祖父阿尔弗雷德。所以大家都知道阿尔弗雷德烤焦蛋糕的故事。但关于阿尔弗雷德在阿瑟尼岛还有另一个与食物有关的故事：他一个人坐在那里，觉得很饿，苦思冥想如何击败维京人。
And he sent all his men out to go fishing because they're really running short of supplies. And his men are out there in the shallows, not getting any fish at all. And a poor man turns up hood over his his head um asks alfred for for some food alfred gives him the last bit of food that he has and the man thanks him and then wanders goes off um and then suddenly all the uh all the men who are out fishing start hauling in great quantities of fish and from that point on
他派所有手下去钓鱼，因为他们的补给真的快见底了。他的手下在浅水区忙活，却一条鱼也钓不到。一个戴着风帽的穷人来到他面前，向阿尔弗雷德讨要食物。阿尔弗雷德把他仅剩的一点食物给了这个人，那人向他致谢后便走开了。然后突然之间，所有在外面钓鱼的人都开始网到大量的鱼。从那一刻起，
they have no lack of food and that man was Cuthbert that man it turns out was Cuthbert he appears to Alfred that evening in a dream and says that I will be backing you I favor you I'm going to back your house and so and so it's from that point on Cuthbert becomes a patron saint of the house of Wessex as well as the Northumbrians and so for Athel, who's just annexed Northumbria into his realms, you can see it's incredibly useful. So to dig into that for a second, that's a story presumably created by Wessex propagandists because they want to reach out to the kind of Northumbrian public and to say, we're not conquering you. We are, you know, we're your friends. We really respect your saint. Your
他们再也不缺食物了，而那个人就是卡斯伯特。那个人原来就是卡斯伯特。他在那天晚上给阿尔弗雷德托梦，说他会支持阿尔弗雷德，他偏爱阿尔弗雷德，他将支持阿尔弗雷德的家族。所以从那一刻起，卡斯伯特成为了威塞克斯王室以及诺森比亚人的主保圣人。因此，对于刚刚将诺森比亚并入自己领地的埃塞尔斯坦来说，你可以看出这极其有用。为了深入探讨这一点，这大概是威塞克斯的宣传人员编造的故事吧，因为他们想向诺森比亚公众伸出橄榄枝，说我们不是来征服你们的。我们是，你知道的，我们是你们的朋友。我们非常尊敬你们的圣人。你们的
saint has actually chosen us. That's what's going on there, surely. I think that's a hard-nosed 21st century perspective that ignores the degree to which this was real for people. So of course, Athelstan knows full well that he needs to get the Northumbrians on side. And of course, he knows that by showing his respect to Cuthbert, he's going to get Northumbrian support. But Athelstan is a highly devout man, and he would not be doing this if he thought it was just a scam. He really believes this. I remember when I was a student, I was studying the Byzantine Empire,
圣人实际上选择了我们。当时的情况肯定就是这样，毋庸置疑。我认为这是一个带有21世纪功利色彩的视角，它忽视了这对当时的人们来说是多么真实。所以当然，埃塞尔斯坦很清楚他需要争取诺森比亚人的支持。而且当然，他知道通过表达对卡斯伯特的敬意，他将获得诺森比亚人的支持。但埃塞尔斯坦是一个高度虔诚的人，如果他认为这只是一场骗局，他是不会这么做的。他是真的相信这一点。记得我还是个学生的时候，我在研究拜占庭帝国，
having an argument with my tutor because I said, but we know that icons don't have powers. And he said, well, well no you can't approach this subject you know thinking that thinking in that way and my question to you is you know we think that all this is balderdash basically did people at the time absolutely completely believe that you know eagles have been providing cuthbert with fish, that people had been... There was no hint of scepticism. They completely signed up to this. Because otherwise he wouldn't have the power
我和导师争论过，因为我说，但我们知道圣像并没有法力。他说，不，你不能带着这种思维方式去探讨这个主题。我的问题是，我们觉得这一切都是胡扯，当时的民众难道完全、百分之百地相信老鹰一直在给卡斯伯特提供鱼吗？人们……当时没有任何怀疑的迹象吗？他们完全接受了这一点。因为否则他就没有力量
to have a body successfully govern it. People have to believe that it's powerful. And I think what's interesting is the longer Cuthbert gets, the more the emphasis comes to be on his power rather than on his charity. So this man who had spent a lot of time with women comes to be cast as a misogynist. And when in due course his body gets enshrined in a great shrine in Durham Cathedral, which is his final resting place, women aren't allowed to enter it. And he becomes a great patron of, ultimately, of English resistance to the Scots, even though Cuthbert was born within what becomes Scotland.
让一具尸体成功统治了。人们必须相信它是充满力量的。我认为有趣的是，卡斯伯特去世的时间越久，人们对他的强调就越集中在他的神力上，而不是他的慈悲上。所以这个曾经花很多时间与女性相处的男人，后来被描绘成了一个厌女者。当他的遗体最终被供奉在杜伦大教堂（他的最终安息之地）的一个宏伟神龛中时，女性是不被允许进入的。他最终成为了英格兰抵抗苏格兰人入侵的伟大主保圣人，尽管卡斯伯特实际上出生在日后成为苏格兰的土地上。
He is seen as the patron of the English in their wars against Scottish invaders. And I think that there is, one of the reasons why I do find Cuthbert a haunting figure is that I do think there is, you know, you say it's all balderdash, but there is something kind of haunting about perhaps his body. Because I said that Cuthbert embodies a kind of living tradition that I think is unique because he almost uniquely survives the reformation because that's the great kind of break yeah when all the other saints are basically broken up and they get literally broken up yeah yeah bunged on rubbish tips burnt whatever um Thomas Cromwell's agents arrive in Durham and they dis they they get rid of the shrine the great, and they open up Cuthbert's tomb. And there they find that the body is, it's, there it is. It's not a skeleton. Please tell me, it's not still preserved.
他被视为英格兰人在与苏格兰入侵者战争中的主保圣人。我认为，这也是为什么我发现卡斯伯特是一个挥之不去的人物的原因之一，因为我的确觉得——你可能会说这全都是胡扯，但他的遗体本身确实有一种挥之不去的魔力。因为我刚才说过，卡斯伯特体现了一种活生生的传统，我认为这是独一无二的，因为他是几乎绝无仅有的在宗教改革中幸存下来的圣人，因为那是巨大的决裂期，是的，当时其他所有圣人都基本上被砸碎了，字面意义上的砸碎，是的，是的，被扔进垃圾堆，付之一炬，无论什么命运……托马斯·克伦威尔的特工抵达杜伦，他们废除了那个伟大的神龛，并打开了卡斯伯特的陵墓。在那里，他们发现遗体竟然——它就在那里。它不是一具骨架。求求你告诉我，它没有被完整保存下来。
You're not going to make that claim. It's been mummified. Okay. And I guess it's, you know, if you want to pursue the sceptical line, you can say that's because he was such an, no, no, it's because he was, he was probably so ascetic that he naturally mummified that maybe there was no kind of liquids in it or whatever i don't know um that seems very unlikely but but what we know is that um cromwell's agents were unsettled by this and so they remove the body and they they kind of lay it out in a kind of side chapel for for two years and then they bury it so they they put it in a fresh tomb and they bury it and it's it's still there so the body of cuthbert is still in durham cathedral his relics are still there and you know it's it's it's a link to to that very ancient those ancient
你不会要做出这种断言吧。它被做成木乃伊了。好吧，我想，如果你想坚持怀疑论的话，你可以说那是因为他是一个——不，不，那是因为他可能太苦行了，所以自然成了木乃伊，也许里面没有什么体液之类的，我不知道……这似乎不太可能，但我们所知道的是，克伦威尔的特工对此感到不安，于是他们移走了遗体，将其陈列在一个侧礼拜堂里两年，然后将它埋葬。所以他们把它放进了一个崭新的陵墓里并将其埋葬，它现在依然在那里。所以卡斯伯特的遗体依然在杜伦大教堂里，他的圣物依然在那里，你知道的，这是一个与基督教极其古老的起源相连的纽带，这种纽带在其他任何地方都不存在了。那么，汤姆，你为什么要废除圣乔治呢？因为这正是你想做的，对吧？你想废除圣乔治，换成圣卡斯伯特。我的意思是，要想说服英格兰的球迷们去为圣卡斯伯特欢呼，你恐怕任重道远。但你的理由是什么？你打算怎么向广大公众推销这一点？
beginnings of christianity that simply doesn't exist anywhere else. And what's your case, Tom, for ditching St. George? Because that's what you want to do, right? You want to ditch St. George and you want St. Cuthbert. I mean, I think you've got an uphill task persuading, you know, England's football fans that they should be cheering for St. Cuthbert. But what's your case? How are you going to sell this to the great public?
圣乔治踢过足球吗？我不觉得。但卡斯伯特踢过。我想他们会支持他的。你觉得呢？卡斯伯特的问题也在于他的名字。这个名字听起来有点浮夸，我觉得。但他恰恰一点都不浮夸。
Did St. George play football? I don't think so. Cuthbert did. I think they'd rally behind him. You reckon? The trouble with Cuthbert is the name as well. The name is slightly foppish, I think. But he's the opposite of foppish.
他一点都不浮夸。他是第一位伟大的英格兰圣人。我的意思是，他是最伟大的英格兰圣人……他是第一位伟大的圣人，他是第一位伟大的英格兰圣人，我的意思是，他是最伟大的英格兰圣人，而且我想乔治并不是英格兰人，而卡斯伯特是北方的圣人，但他也是被威塞克斯诸王采纳的圣人，所以他是一个地地道道的英格兰圣人。他的遗体原封不动地留在诺森比亚，而且他具有显神迹的能力，这种能力甚至一直延续到了20世纪。据说，当纳粹空军逼近纽卡斯尔，准备对其进行轰炸时，
He's the opposite of foppish. He's the first great English saint. I mean, he's the greatest English saint,ish he's he's the first great saint he's the first great english saint i mean he's the greatest english saint i think and i guess george isn't english and cuthbert is is the saint of the north but he's also the saint that gets adopted by the kings of wessex so he's he's a properly english saint um his his body has remains there in situ in in northumbria and he has a capacity to work work miracles that survived even into the 20th century. So it's said that as the Luftwaffe were approaching Newcastle, getting ready to bomb it,
他一点也不浮华造作。他是第一位伟大的英国圣徒。我的意思是，他是最伟大的英国圣徒，他是第一位伟大的圣徒，他是第一位伟大的英国圣徒，我的意思是，我认为他是最伟大的英国圣徒，而且我想乔治也不是英国人，而卡斯伯特是北方的圣徒，但他也是被威塞克斯国王们采纳的圣徒，所以他是一位名副其实的英国圣徒，嗯，他的遗体依然留在诺森布里亚原址，并且他具有显神迹的能力，这种能力甚至一直延续到了20世纪。因此据说，当德国空军接近纽卡斯尔，准备对其进行轰炸时，
that prayers were raised across the Northeast asking for Cuthbert's intercession and a great fog descended on the Tyne. Wow. Fog on the Tyne. Fog on the Tyne and the Luftwa turned around fog on the time and uh the luffa turned around and um newcastle was saved so i think this is this is this is a saint who who means business tom i my skepticism is at an end i am fully persuaded i shall go out forthwith on this
整个东北部的人们都在祈祷，祈求卡斯伯特的代祷，于是泰恩河上降下了一场大雾。哇。泰恩河上的大雾。泰恩河上的大雾，纳粹空军掉头回去了。泰恩河上的大雾，纳粹空军掉头回去了，纽卡斯尔得救了。所以我想，这是一个真正的圣人，汤姆。我的怀疑主义已经烟消云散，我被彻底说服了。我这就出发，在卡斯伯特日这一天，试着唤起广大英国公众——或者说广大英格兰公众——将卡斯伯特奉为我们的主保圣人。那么，这就是我们这期关于卡斯伯特的特别版——是叫“卡斯伯特式的”吗？我想是的，创造这个词吧。关于卡斯伯特式的《The Rest Is History》到此结束。汤姆，
and cuthbert's day and attempt to to to rouse the great British public, or the great English public anyway, in adopting Cuthbert as our patron saint. So, that concludes our special Cuthbertian, is Cuthbertian? I think so, yeah, I mean, coin that. Cuthbertian edition of The Rest is History. And Tom,
我们下周将带着大量的精彩节目回归，不是吗？我们周一有一期关于“首相世界杯”的节目。我们周二还有另一期关于“首相世界杯”的节目。因为我们对英国首相有太多话要说了。我们对英国首相有太多话要说了。然后我们在周末将邀请间谍小说家本·麦金太尔（Ben Macintyre）来聊聊间谍，这绝对令人兴奋。
we are back next week with a plethora of episodes, aren't we? We've got one on Monday about the World Cup of Prime Ministers. We have another on Tuesday about the World Cup of Prime Ministers. Because we had so much to say. We had so much to say about Britain's Prime Ministers. And then we are back at the end of the week with Spies and Ben McIntyre, which is immensely exciting.
祝大家周末愉快，我们下周见。圣卡斯伯特日快乐，再见，再见。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要获取独家附赠节目、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
So have a good weekend and we'll see you next week. Happy St Cuthbert's day bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那么祝大家周末愉快，我们下周见。圣卡斯伯特日快乐，再见，再见，感谢收听《历史的剩余》，想要获取独家节目、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。